-Welcome to the show.
-Thank you.
-Jamie, It's great to meet you.
It's so nice to meet you.
I'm happy you're here.
-It's a pleasure to be here.
I'm so grateful.
Thank you so much, Jimmy.
-I have a lot to talk to you.
congratulations on everything
with "Stranger Things."
I mean, it's the biggest thing.
You joined the season this year
as the villain, as Vecna.
You instantly became
a fan favorite.
People love you.
And...
[ Cheers and applause ]
There it is.
How much of a...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love that -- did you ever
think that you would ever get
to play a character and wear all
these prosthetics? I mean...
-Absolutely not.
I mean, I never even imagined
I would be on
a show like this, let alone
playing this thing.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's amazing.
It was just such a blessing.
The whole thing feels like such
a whirlwind since I got it.
It's bizarre.
-How much is CGI
and how much is real?
-It's about 90 percent real.
So it takes about eight hours
to put the whole thing on,
so I have to kind of...
[ Audience groans ]
Thank you, I appreciate that.
[ Laughter ]
I feel sorry for me, too.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I'm working with Barry Gower,
who's amazing, who works on
"Game of Thrones"
and "The Witcher."
Duncan Jarman, Mike McCash,
Nicks and Eric Garcia.
Shoutout to those guys.
Thank you so much.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Um, yeah, so it's about eight
hours in the process.
And we start at like 3:00 A.M.
in the morning
to be ready for about
10:00, and then --
-And then you have to act.
-And then I have to act, yeah.
-And how fast is it to take off?
-It's about an hour,
hour and a half, yeah.
-Yeah. I like these random
photos they took of you
behind the scenes,
like backstage.
Your fellow cast members
who love you so much.
They just take photos of you
and post them on the Internet.
Here is one of Vecna
drinking a Starbucks,
which is just thought...
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
I just love that.
You got to have a little
caffeine in there, yeah.
-Always, yeah.
-Always.
-That's only way
to get through. really.
Powered by caffeine, Vecna.
There you go.
-And when you do the -- on top
of the physical transformation,
the voice of Vecna,
did you always know
which voice
you were going to go with?
-No. It took -- it took
a few months to get right.
We had to read through
in March of 2020,
and I had been doing a bit of
work on Vecna and on Henry.
I only got the job in January,
so I had kind of February
to prepare for it.
We did the read through,
and I was there
kind of at the table
reading with everyone.
I sat behind Milly,
and I was doing the voice
and it started in this
like very kind of like
nasally kind of area,
kind of more like
Freddie Krueger
and it just wasn't landing.
So I went home and worked on it,
did a bunch of reference work
on like "Hellraiser"
and Doug Bradley,
in particularly.
And said that, you know, this
deep, booming voice
kind of comes out
of the darkness.
And I was like, "Oh, yeah.
You can tell."
-Yeah.
You're getting somewhere.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I like that.
-I loved it.
It was amazing.
So I just kind
of worked on that,
and I'm a singer so I kind
of just relaxed myself,
relaxed my larynx.
You're a singer, so you know
what it's like.
Relax your --
I've seen you sing.
You can sing.
Don't give me that.
-No, I mean, you're a singer.
I sing. I sing,
but you're a singer.
That's the difference, yeah.
You actually have a new song
coming out August 12th.
-I do, yes.
-August 12th.
It's called "I Am."
-Yes.
-Congrats.
Are you excited for that?
-I'm so excited.
Everything just feels
not real right now.
-It's all happening.
-Yes.
-I mean, that's soon.
August 12th.
-Yeah, it's like two weeks away.
-Yeah, so guys, look for "I Am,"
who's coming out,
yeah, Jamie's new song.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And then on top of that,
I heard that you're also
filming a movie
with Kevin Costner.
-I am.
Yes, you get the exclusive.
I'm doing a Western saga
with Mr. Kevin Costner.
I'll be -- Yeah, I know, wild.
I'll be in, I think,
Utah in October
riding a horse
wearing a Stetson.
-I mean, come on!
-I know, I know.
-That's a dream right there.
With Kevin Costner?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Who's also a good musician.
-Amazing musician.
-Yeah, you should jam with him.
-I heard some of it
like two weeks ago.
-It's good.
-I was in a fitting,
and I just heard it,
it's amazing.
He's so talented.
-I was listening
to your stuff today.
I know you're in a band,
I listened to your songs.
But also I found out
this very cool things.
I didn't know.
I knew the voice
before I heard Vecna.
And I realized that you're
also the voice
of Skiff from
"Thomas & Friends."
-[ Laughs ]
-This is real.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is true.
-Yeah.
-It's hard to believe that these
are both the same person.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, Vecna and...
-[ Laughs ]
[ Applause ]
-And just for fun, we wanted to
see what would sound like
if you had used your Vecna
voice for Skiff.
-Oh, my goodness.
-Check this out.
-Okay.
-[ Deep voice ] It is time
that I bring you to join me.
-There you go.
It's very frightening.
-[ Laughs ]
-Skiff.
[ Applause ]
Fans of "Stranger Things"
have called Vecna
the scariest character
that they have ever seen.
He's pretty terrifying.
I was wondering if you wouldn't
mind doing the Vecna voice
for us right now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-For you Jimmy, anything.
I got you, I got you.
-But here's what we did.
What we did, we put some
of your lines on cue cards.
-Okay.
-Okay, and the twist
is that there are all things
that Vecna would never say.
Okay.
-Whenever you're ready.
Roots, can you give us
a little music?
[ Sinister music playing ]
-I'm sorry about this everyone.
[ Laughter ]
[ Deep voice ] I'm just a girl
standing in front of a boy,
asking him to love her.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Try this on, try this on.
This is it.
-I'm cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Jack, oh, Jack.
I want you to draw me like one
of your French girls.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Normal voice ] This is a daily
affirmation for Vecna, okay?
[ Laughter ]
[ Deep voice ] I am strong.
I am beautiful.
I am kind.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-You see it?
-Alright, this is for you,
Jimmy.
-Okay, I really beg you
do this one.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
In a minute, I'ma need a
sentimental man
or woman to pump you up.
Feeling fussy, walkin
in my balenci-ussy's
tryna bring out the fabulous.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That is how you do it!
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Jamie Campbell Bower as
Vecna in "Stranger Things."
Take a look at this!
-But in the end,
he could not control us.
He could not shape us.
He could not change us.
Do you not see, Eleven.
He did not make me into this.
You did.
♪♪
-Jamie Campbell Bower, everyone.
Season four of "Stranger Things"
streaming now on Netflix.
August 12th, "I Am."
We'll be right back with a
performance from King Princess!
Stick around, everybody!